let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 next we're gonna go to our
caller from the 808 area code caller go
ahead hello that's you who's this
there's a key on him all right go ahead
from origin oh all right anyways first
of all I wanna say I really love your
show man I'm pretty much watching it
every day thank you but my question is
is what do you think of Marxist theory
and how might it or might not apply to
today today's economy like just very
generally Marxist theory yeah I'm as the
as the audience knows I'm not a Marxist
I'm not a communist I'm not a socialist
I think that the value theory of labor
from Marx is very very interesting and
it actually should be a fundamental
element of economics as taught
everywhere because it explains to us in
a really really straightforward way how
you take all these raw materials and you
put them together and you end up with
something that's worth more than the sum
of its parts well where is that value
coming from that is coming from the
productivity of the labor that's putting
it together and then you can have a
better understanding and be better
prepared to discuss where and how should
that how should that surplus value be
allocated in terms of should it go to
the capitalists or owners should it go
to the workers how should decisions
about that allocation be made so I think
that you know I took Marxian economics
in college and I think it's hugely
hugely valuable and it'd be great if it
was taught more all over the country not
to make people communists or socialists
or Marxist but to better they're
understood perfectly that ok ok cool
awesome thank you very much all right
well thank you I appreciate the call